الينا من اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي يوسف ريم
السيد يوسف مرحبا بك معنا اذا بالنظر الى
النتائج
ما هو شكل التحالفات في الايام القليله
المقبله
حتى موعد الجوله الثانيه
ننظر الى سنان اوغن وهو المرشح الثالث
الذي لن يشارك في الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات وننظر الى قاعدته
فقاعدته في هذا
الحل هم من القوميين
وهو ايضا عضو السابق من الحركه القوميه
التركيه والتي تعتبر جزءا من تحالف
اردوغان تحالف الجمهور اذا في الراي العام
بشانه كيفيه السلوك الناخبين بين انصار
سنان اوغان على الارجح سيكون هناك تحول
منهم الى
تحالف الجمهور بزعامه اردوغان وذلك بسبب
الانسجام في الافكار بالنسبه
لتحالف الامه الذي يجعله اوغلو فان الوجود
الخارجي
لحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الذي يدعم
فهذا يعتبر خطا احمر لانصاري سنان اوغان
وايضا اوغلو قام بادلاء بوعد لاستقلاليه
للاكراد اذا فهذا لا يناسبه سنان اوغن ولا
انصاره اذا
الان ارى ان الوضع صعب لانصار سنان اوغان
ان يقوموا
بدعم كمالك الاشجار اذا فسنان اوغان رغم
انه يبدو بانه لديه خيارات الا ان الوضع
ليس كذلك وخياره الاوحد الان هو يتمثل فيه
دعمي تحالف الجمهور اذا
فستمر عمليه الاخذ والعطاء لكن اعتقد ان
انصاره سوف يذهبون لدعمي تحالف الجمهور
الذي يزعمه اردوغان سيدنا يوسف السيد سنان
اوغان وضع مجموعه من الشروط من اجل ان
يؤيد احد
المرشحين تعتقدون بان الرئيس اردوغان قادر
على تلبيه هذه الشروط او ما شكل التسويه
الممكنه التي ممكن ان ترضي الطرفين
اردوغان وسنان او كلجدار والسنان
دعونا نتحدث عن الحل الوسط من اوغلو الذي
يريده هو يريده منه
انى بنفسه عن حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي والذي
ترشح باسم اليسار الاخضر الذي استخدمه في
الانتخابات هذه هو يريد له ان يناى عن هذا
الحزب ويريد ان لا تتحقق الاستقلاليه
للاكراد اذا كمالك الاجدار اوغلو ومن
ناحيه حسابيه لن يتخلى عن 9% لكي يحصل على
5% فهذا من ناحيه حسابيه ليس منطقيا ولن
يكون لصالح كمال كالاجله بالنسبه لاردوغان
هو حقا ليس عليه ان يقدم الكثير من
التنازلات لكي يحصل على اصوات اوغان ولا
يريد ان يرى بانه ضعيف او انه يستسلم
ويدعن فقط لكي يحصل على بعض الدعم من
انصاري سنان اوغن هو يمكن له ان يحصل على
هذا الدعم بدون التنازلات ولكن قد يبدو
بانه يريد ان يكون براجماتيا وان يقدم بعض
الوعود لاوغان بطريقه محدوده وهو يمكن ان
يستخدم كوسيط
الحركه القوميه لكي يكونوا قادرين على
الحديث اليه لنقاش هذه القضايا اذن
اردوغان لديه الكثير من الادوات التي يمكن
ان يستخدمها لكي يحقق ما يريد شكرا لك سيد
يوسف ريم الكاتب الصحفي كنت معنا من
اسطنبول